it's up everyone we are back on the ving
Jane we're gonna be talking about how
illness is optional alright Naveen how
is ill this optional well first of all
when I say illness I really mean chronic
diseases which are you know non
communicable diseases not the
communicable disease I'm not talking
about infection you know god forbid we
get infection and there is nothing we
can do about it I'm talking about the
chronic diseases that's not something
that happens to you overnight it happens
over time you know you don't go out and
say honey I was out with Ellen last
night I think I might I might have
caught diabetes today you don't catch
diabetes you don't catch obesity you
don't catch autoimmune diseases you
don't really catch Parkinson you don't
catch Alzheimer you don't catch
depression you don't catch anything
citee these are all the chronic diseases
interesting thing is the chronic
diseases happen for one single reason
chronic low-grade inflammation nothing
else the chronic low-grade inflammation
causes chronic diseases because it
builds up over time and causes the
long-term so when you have a chronic
low-grade inflammation it's like pulling
on a chain it always breaks at the
weakest link and different people have
different link links so some people will
break because they get hard to see some
people get diabetes some people get
obesity some people get Alzheimer's some
people get cancer but the root causes
the low-grade chronic inflammation and
the chronic inflammation happens when
your gut is imbalance and when you have
got imbalance gut it causes your gut
lining to be permeable that means the
food that you're eating and the bacteria
and viruses in the East and the fun they
start to seep into the blood line and
your immune system is constantly now
under attack because it's seeing stuff
that is never saw it's not supposed to
see food in the blood it's not supposed
to see these viruses and bacteria all it
does every time is see something it
starts to attack it and it's constantly
it the best way it can attack is to
inflame remember every time there is a
infraction most thing it does inflame
and that inflammation if it's constantly
there it essentially becomes chronic
disease
so our healthcare system I want to spend
just going on a soapbox for 30 second
our modern health care system has
fundamentally designed to keep everyone
sick every stakeholder in the car health
care system only makes money when you
are sick they don't make money when
you're healthy so imagine like a social
media business plan as well as the
attention economy they get paid more of
the more ads you see so the health care
system can be incentivized to keep us
healthy that's a but to be imagined when
you are not sick you don't get to see
the doctor doctor makes no money
Hospital makes no money
pharmaceutical companies make no money
an insurance company you would think our
beneficiary they are not by law they
have to give back 85 percent of their
premium to the policyholders so if
you're if you are healthy they are to
define your premium they don't like that
so they would rather keep you sick
pharmaceutical companies love chronic
diseases chronic diseases to me to them
means his subscription business
subscription price and quad diabetes of
Kerching for rest of your life you have
a drug they don't want to find out what
caused it you have autoimmune diseases
let's not find out why you got that you
know just suppress the immune system
because when we suppress it you keep it
for rest of your life
you're going to keep taking my drug but
when you suppress the immune system doc
don't you think I'm going to get more
diseases oh yeah but we got drugs for
them too but doc if I take those drugs
don't you think I'm going to get more to
seize it
oh yeah but we got we got rats for them
too and what happens is they give you
drug for one disease that causes three
diseases then they give you three more
drugs that causes nine more diseases and
then they give you nine more drugs and
by that time you get to my age you're
popping more pills than blueberries
that's really what the pharmaceutical
companies like they don't want to cure
anything now the only person who doesn't
want to be sick is a person who is sick
and that's the reason I believe for the
first time we believe if we can tell the
person who is safe
what is causing it and what they can do
about it and what if the only drug they
need is the food and if they could find
out there what food is good for them and
they can find out what food is bad for
them yep and you know everybody said oh
my god what a brilliant guy he's in all
these great science this is not new this
is what we knew thousands of years ago
you know you go back to Iowa that we
talked about that in Iowa that they used
to talk about people are really
individual some are coppa some are PETA
are some are mixture and there's some
food that are good for one person that's
not good for another person when they're
near worth it what's inside you Sankar
and here is the best part
2,400 years ago a doctor named
Hippocrates he said all diseases begin
in the gut way back when and then he
said one man's food is another man's
poison yeah means a food that's good for
Paul is not necessarily good for Elam
even the food that good for Alan today
it may not be good three months from now
because his body had changed now yeah
right yeah and the third thing he said
was really interesting let food be thy
medicine let thy medicine be thy food
yeah and that's it but the point is all
we need is to understand what does our
body needs in terms of nutrients what
kind of food we can provide that will
cause our microbiome to release the
nutrient our body needs what will cause
our microbiome not to release this stuff
that's causing inflammation and if you
can do that then somehow the body will
stay in balance so when you call it this
ease what is this ease body not being at
ease is to get this easy and that's what
we call disease this is simply the body
is not balanced body is not at ease
right so what we do is to understand
every single thing that your body is
producing the enzymes and the peptides
and you say oh you're not producing
enough of this good vitamin folic acid
or vitamin K
or butyrate what kind of organisms do
you have they are capable of doing it
what kind of foods we can give you now
to essentially change that now these
organisms are producing too much or bad
stuff what do we need to stop feeding
them so that we don't get that or you
don't have enough organism that can
produce this good stuff called butyrate
can we give you the butyl supplement now
so at least in the short term and then
we introduce what really happens is most
organisms may be there but they are
really being suppressed by all other
stuff and when you start to get rid of
the bad stuff by not feeding them
suddenly this stuff it starts to grow
and when this starts to grow or now they
can start to produce good stuff right so
your body is changing and adapting so
think of your gut microbiome like a
seesaw and you start to bring it into
balance and if you don't change your
diet again it goes in balance the other
way so you have to constantly straddle
and change it just like joining your car
every year your body is locked more
complex you gotta tune it every three or
four months and you keep it balanced and
when you do that and if you don't clean
your body what happens you end up in a
repair shop is called ER yeah right
emergency room that's where you end up
so the reason we believe the chronic
disease is optional is you know what is
happening inside you've got what is
causing your depression what's causing
you anxiety what is causing you not to
be able to sleep what's causing you not
to have lot of energy what is causing
you not to be you and we can now analyze
your gut and tell you what foods are
good for you
what are bad for you do you really need
some supplements that your body actually
is not producing and that's really what
keeps your body in balance and if you do
that then your body becomes at ease and
that's why we believe it's optional so
we never said we can create a world
where no one is sick because that tells
you the power is inside us what we're
saying is it's optional that means you
have the power our job is to empower you
to make that
and if we give you the actionable things
you can do that this chronic disease can
be completely optional that's what
really well said and you also blew my
mind when you were talking about how
there's no one food that's the biggest
universal myth is that there's one one
food that's good for everybody
that Elias all right there is no such
thing as universal healthy food a food
that's good for one person can harm
another person so you know I think we
talked about in the past that you know
everyone teeny spinach is healthy yeah
we know for half the people is spinach
actually causes more harm than good
because spinach has so much of oxalic
acid and if you gut microbiome cannot be
toxify oxalic acid into something benign
then that oxalic acid is going to end up
at the kidney stone or cause more
inflammation same type I think people
think you know there may be something
like kale or Roma yeah all of them stuff
writer for that person yes or you look
at the things like a pomegranate juice
almonds raspberry people say oh these
are antioxidative food they're really
good for me what they don't realize is
these foods are not antioxidative these
foods simply contain the compound called
allergic acid and that allergic acid is
converted by your gut microbiome into
something called you roll it in a and
that is antioxidative so if your body
doesn't have the enzyme it's not
producing the enzymes and peptides that
can convert allergic acid into you roll
it in a then the best thing that happens
is you're pissing off your money the
worst thing is these things are causing
harm and that's why you get
recommendations so okay let's let's
let's do that in this next in this next
part we'll talk about the actual
recommendations yeah engine yeah all
right great